let's talk about false rape and sexual
assault accusations my position on this
issue has been clear for a very long
time unless I have a specific reason to
disbelieve a rape or sexual assault
accuser my default is to trust the
victims
why because false rape accusations are
relatively rare because I know that
there is massive stigma for people even
coming forward about being the victims
of sexual assault and rape and as I said
before any social welfare system is
going to have some freeriders any crime
reporting system is going to have some
false reports but mathematically we need
to consider whether we would append
those systems as a result of that small
percentage of people however and this is
where now some on the left may not be so
pleased with me I have also said that
when there are known false rape
allegations it has to be taken seriously
by the criminal justice system because
in the same way that we want to reduce
the stigma around reporting of sexual
assault so that victims feel more
comfortable coming forward we need to
make it absolutely clear as a society
that false accusations cannot be
tolerated a woman has now been sent to
jail for 45 days for making up a story
about being raped by a black man in a
delta college parking lot I'm talking
about 21 year old Marysville Kowski
who's been sentenced to not only those
45 days in jail but also two years of
probation with 220 days of deferred jail
meaning if she violates probation she
would have to serve 220 additional days
and as we now understand the story Zell
Kowski says she was previously sexually
assaulted not anybody on the Delta
college campus not a black guy but that
she was ashamed to come forward
initially and ended up apparently
projecting a prior sexual assault onto a
vague black man on the college campus it
now is unclear whether she was even
actually sexually assaulted prior to the
accusation of rape that she made against
this amorphous black man on the Delta
college campus police heard her story
originally started investigating it and
found absolutely no evidence whatsoever
they
actually did find a black guy with a
criminal record on the Delta college
campus
brought him in for a polygraph test
which the guy passed and ultimately
Tolkowsky admitted to police that the
story is not true this has to be taken
very seriously and if there is any
argument to be made it's that 45 days
isn't enough and the reason why I think
it may not be enough is that the person
who could have ended up in prison based
on the false rape claim could have
gotten 20 years in prison Wow and the
only case for 45 days instead of more
for this woman would be that number one
as prescribed by the law the max she
could have gotten was six months for
false reporting of a felony that's how
the law is currently written and number
two her lawyer said that she suffers
from bipolar disorder and I am 100%
sensitive to the impact of mental
illness on behavior but the primary
point is you can like me have your
default tendency be that you trust the
victims but you can still recognize that
false accusations exist and have to be
taken seriously and this is yet another
one of these political footballs you've
got the men's rights activist world
you've got this sort of Venn diagram of
the gamergate all right outright anti
sjw Enclave they will often push the
idea that either you're against the
false rape accusations or you don't care
about them and you blindly believe every
victim the reality is more complex the
reality is that false rape accusations
are rare but they exist and by default
we trust but verify when it comes to
victims and that's what police did here
right when you turn up false accusations
you prosecute them in this case it's the
false reporting of a felony which is the
way the law is written but the system
work is designed at least in this case
if you don't think that that's true if
you believe that even this case is
representative of a problem within the
system then let me know I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman let me know on my Instagram
page David Pakman wherever but I think
that this is actually evidence that the
system worked that these false
allegations are relatively rare and
system caught it and the perpetrator is
being punished we can debate whether the
punishment is just whether it's too
harsh or not harsh enough but the system
did work in this case